[Music]
today's episode is about Jesse Owens and
the 1936 Berlin Olympics which are
[ __ ] wild and we're gonna have some
interesting observations coming at you
in a little bit so this one's gonna be
what you call a little bit of a
tightrope walk yeah because of the times
of the zeitgeist but were [ __ ] diving
headfirst into it Jesse Owens uh he went
to Ohio State the Ohio State University
that's why I was called the Buckeye
bullet um and he was the best track and
field athlete in the NCAA at a 1935 Big
Ten track meeting in Michigan Jesse
perhaps he had the greatest set of track
and field offense in the history of
track in the history of track in just 45
minutes of competition
Jesse tied one world record in the
hundred yard sprint and broke three
world records into the 220 yard sprint
cuz in 45 minutes the kids said three
world records I mean yeah yeah I'm out
of breath going up three flights of
stairs yeah and the reason why it's you
know to bring up that he said three
world records in 45 minutes and how
unbelievably talented this man was and
probably the best athlete our country
had he didn't even receive a scholarship
to Ohio State he had to keep working
part-time jobs because of the racism at
that University they wouldn't give him a
scholarship when he clear and away was
the best athlete that this could mean
it's actually insane that he was he was
the best runner in the country and he
had to pay to go to school so the kid
had to work a part-time job go to class
and then run like all the other white
kids who were on scholarship
I mean brutes mcgoats i'm voting that
bruits magoons because i love doing this
podcast with you because not only do I
get the people on my best friend
Sergeant snuggles but we just learn so
much and so many things especially now
in such a turbulent time in our history
it's like you look back in history and
you see like there's a lot of things are
happening back then they're happening
today it goes again the history is
repeating itself yeah I mean you know
this country has had a problem with race
I think since the beginning I mean I
think it's not an exaggeration to say
that we got a little situation with the
racism in this country you got to
understand one thing about 1920's 1930's
Olympic athletes at that time I mean it
wasn't easy for a black kid to even make
the Olympic team as a matter of fact
right before the 1936 Olympics they
weren't even the government or the
United States government did not even
want to allow black athletes to compete
on
Team USA and that's a big problem that's
a big problem if you want to win golds
that's the thing is if you want to win
you should have the black guys on your
team yeah it's 1936 Berlin Olympics of
course you know there's a name you know
rounding out this is Adolf Hitler Adolf
Hitler just become the leader the Nazi
Party just taken over absolute power and
it's interesting Adolf Hitler as you do
the research on him which a lot I think
people know but don't know it's he
himself
many people think was at least 25%
Jewish and the Aryan race that he was
touting which was blond hair blue eyes
as the ubermensch the you know that the
ultraman he was under those things I
mean he was a short squeak of the kid
with brown hair and a little baby
mustache and what many people say is
micro Pina so he was wanted he was kind
of advocating for something he didn't
look like so in many ways he was doing
history's version of Shaun King cuz
Shorty's a white kid that's advocated
for black people so you know so I'm not
saying I mean I know showing Kings
trying to do good but make no mistake he
is WH ite yeah I mean that is hilarious
Adolf Hitler in some way was the Shaun
King of his day in that clip it yeah he
was he was advocating for tall blond
Aryan looking kids and make no mistake
that kid he did anyone look more like a
Bosnian accountant than Adolf 1936 as
Dallas was saying Jesse Owens was given
all the amenities that he should have
been getting in the United States so he
said the German people treated him more
fair than his emit than his American
countryman did because he was able he
couldn't believe when he got to the
Olympic barracks he was like where are
our rooms because he was speaking for
the black athletes he was like where are
rooms and the German people like no you
all stay together this is one big happy
family so there's a lot of [ __ ] that
goes on of course the major [ __ ] of
why we're having segregation in the
United States supposed to be this free
prosperous you know beacon of you know
freedom but the Germans who were
secretly obviously in a few years going
to invade Poland and really show their
message we're acting as if there were
these great people because they weren't
segregating the whites from the blacks
yes so it's very interesting you know
them and that was all Joseph Goebbels
was
Joseph Goebbels so we spoken about him
many times if you don't know go google
him he's the propaganda he was the Nazi
propaganda minister and these were all
his designs of having the whole world
look at them in the 1936 Olympics he all
of a sudden all the the hating Jews
signs were taken down all the you know
Jewish athletes were allowed to come
back and compete you know under all
these certain guises but you know so the
cameras are on them and everybody thinks
all the Nazis aren't that bad
but of course they weren't Jesse Owens
and a man by the name of Lutz long who
was that who was actually Jesse Owens
main rival because Jett Lutz long was
the only one who could even come close
to competing with him and they struck up
this amazing friendship Jesse Owens he
had faulted twice on the long jump and
if he fought one more time they're
disqualified and Lutz long came over in
the middle in front of Adolf Hitler and
said hey if you put a towel down right
before the line
that'll give your mind a cue and you'll
be able to jump from there and then he
put the towel down jumped set the record
won the gold medal and the first person
after he set that world record jump the
first person hug him was Lutz long right
in front of Hitler and the rest of the
German officers eyes and he's just a
special guy and then remained friends
until Lutz long died which is wild which
is a wild thing so Jesse Owens wins four
medals becomes friends with Lutz Long's
comes back home doesn't get the Welcome
that he would like cuz he's a black kid
he's got to go back now and try to find
a job kid couldn't find a job I mean you
know he he pumped gas for a little while
I'm like it's crazy and he's famously
quoted as saying you know yeah I got
four gold medals but you can't eat four
gold medals there you go so yeah II guy
he had to make money and the kid became
a smoker ironic is that I it's ironic I
did thirty two years old thirty twos dad
kissed our smoke away he ended up dying
and it was 66 from lung cancer as a
sprinter
I mean cities are good cities are good
yeah they taste good they make the pain
go away yeah yeah Jesse Owens was not
treated fairly I mean that kid after
doing that especially at that time
especially after what was gonna happen
to World War two I mean it's like that
kid shouldn't ever have to pay taxes
again he should just be given free room
and board by the US government and him
and his family for the rest of our lives
but that's just
and Jesse Owens also said this he said
Hitler didn't snub me it was our
president FDR who some who snub me the
president didn't even send a telegram I
mean you can't even send the [ __ ]
telegram to the kid I mean Luke's long
is writing letters to the enemy from
behind Nazi lines getting him through
you can't even write a telegram the
polio [ __ ] yeah I mean history is filled
with all these dirty after you are
segregated black and white servants at
the White House I mean cause when is his
wheelchair gonna be taken away exactly
they should have took his wheelchair
away as soon as he did that I mean
because if I see make no mistake if I
see a [ __ ] if I see a statue if after
on a wheelchair I'm Tiffany thank you
guys for watching don't forget to
subscribe also turn on alerts more to
come health absolutely and go to
patreon.com/scishow a rich boys to join
the matriarchy where things get really
wild
[Music]